Federal Reserve is doing it again making
a huge mistake that's going to imperil
the U.S economy at least that's what a
growing number of economists asset
managers professors and think tanks are
saying Jay Powell and his colleagues are
making a mistake the Federal Reserve has
been repeatedly making the same mistake
if it made a couple mistakes I'm going
to explain why some top academics and
investors are pushing back on the U.S
Central bank's plans what they think the
FED should be doing instead and why it
matters to the market and for everyday
Americans
the FED got it wrong in 2021 when they
insisted for months that inflation was
transitory and would follow on its own
without getting too hot now chair Jerome
Powell has made inflation Public Enemy
Number One for the fed and says the
central bank will do whatever it takes
to get inflation back down to their two
percent Target so they've raised U.S
interest rates to the highest they've
been since the 2008 Global financial
crisis and plan to raise them even
higher in 2023. economists almost
universally agree that inflation is too
high and many agree with the fed's
approach but an increasingly large and
diverse group from the world of
Economics is warning that the FED is
getting it wrong again Nobel Laureate
Joseph stieglitz for instance argues
that today's inflation is largely driven
by Supply shocks and shifts in demand
rather than increasing demand which is
the problem that raising interest rates
is designed to solve stieglitz says that
raising rates will bring unnecessarily
high unemployment that will
disproportionately hurt low-income
Americans women and people of color
while having only a minimal impact on
inflation similar former labor secretary
Robert reichasserts the FED is missing
the inflation picture because they're
focused on Rising wages for Americans
instead of Corporations record high
profit margins an American Enterprise
Institute senior fellow Desmond Lackman
recently pointed to the declining price
of things like oil Lumber and used cars
he says this is thanks to China's
slowing economy and supply chain
resilience and that the fed's actions
are only going to hurt the economy
critical economists think the FED should
stop raising interest rates now and
rethink its approach Muhammad al-arian
president of Queen's College Cambridge
and chief economic advisor at Allianz
says the FED has lost credibility and
needs to start by owning their mistakes
he believes a recession is unavoidable
now but that the FED can reduce the harm
from What It's Already Done by pulling
back and accepting that inflation is
unlikely to hit their two percent Target
by pushing forward with its plans to
raise rates by at least another one
percent these economists argue the FED
is going to cause Millions more
Americans to lose their jobs there is
also fear that much of the progress that
has been made in the economy like higher
wages decreasing inequality and
increased savings for low-income
families will be lost they also were
that the fed's current course will lead
to the destruction of more small
businesses the FED has given little
acknowledgment to many of these
arguments but as more economists start
to jump on the bandwagon that may change
with the FED raising rates rapper Tyler
the Creator makes a great point about
what to do with your money he says hands
Stay full with them racks like hit
tennis no money phone account going to
get interest
that's all for now see you next time